if you look at health in the United
States you could point to some really
significant achievements and you could
also point to the role that NIH is
played in making those things happen
cardiovascular disease has dropped by
more than sixty percent in mortality
over the course of the last thirty to
forty years much of it from insights
derived from groups like the heart of
the Framingham study which pointed out
what the risk factors were and what we
could do about them cancer is dropping
in its frequency finally after many
years of going up but there are clouds
on the horizon of public health obesity
and it's related disease diabetes
probably is the one that causes the
greatest concern when you see the way in
which our population is growing more
overweight almost year by year with no
sign that we've managed to turn this
around and that could if not somehow
addressed result in an outcome where our
grandchildren will not live as long as
we do and we would therefore turn down
what has been an upward curve in
longevity over many decades a critical
need there through research research
that involves a nutrition research that
involves understanding exercise that
understands the built environment and
how to motivate health behaviors to try
to turn around this obesity epidemic
certainly other areas of concern
Alzheimer's disease comes to mind as a
condition which as our population is
aging and as the boomers are coming into
this phase of potentially higher risk
for Alzheimer's that we're going to see
very large numbers of people affected by
this heartbreaking disease with terrible
consequences for themselves and their
families and for our medical economics
because of the cost of caring for them
so this has to be a very high priority
for high intensity efforts to come up
with new solutions about prevention and
treatment
NIH is intensely interested in
prevention I think everybody would agree
that we haven't paid enough attention to
this approach to maintaining health that
we've not had a health care system in
terms of medical care we've had a sick
care system where if you get sick there
might be some help for you but there's
been relatively little invested in terms
of helping people stay well and maybe as
part of that we've had modest efforts
really to try to invest in research on
prevention that's all changing some of
that's coming about because of a better
understanding of the environment and
things that people should be careful
about as far as bad influences on their
future health whether it's smoking or
diet or exercise we're learning a lot
about that and some of it is the ability
through personalized medicine to begin
to identify individual risks for future
illness to get us beyond the
one-size-fits-all approach to prevention
which has been not that effective people
haven't necessarily warmed to these
recommendations about what you should do
about diet exercise colonoscopies
mammograms and so on because it all
sounds very much generic but if you
could provide people with information
about their personal risks and allow
them therefore to come up with a
personalized plan for maintaining health
that seems to inspire a lot more
interest genomics is moving us in the
direction of being able to do that and I
think that's one of the more exciting
developments in the prevention arena
even though it's early days yet to see
how that's going to play out